the Chinese tradition of our family it's
very strong everyone have to get marry
and have child to keep on the emini
every family cannot accept a gay son so
you will feel guilty you will feel sad
for being gay
being a make my family feels sad
so in February I decided to try to go to
the training to accept achievement it's
a big day today
the phone is TV invite me an iron to
join the TV show talking about the
conversion therapy it's a very big deal
in China because the Chinese TV never
talking about this issue until until
financial donation
what's hey
and you are getting
my friend call me iron and bisexual
queer I'm the director of a Beijing LGBT
Center I'm not sure worried about my
father's family to save me on television
because didn't came to I didn't come to
come out to my father
how could my family face the challenge
from the neighborhood I don't want my
family to be hurt like many people
dispersing to LGBT people are people who
have some mental disease so in China we
still have this kind of commerce and
therapy
the consultant in the clinic that he
hypnosis to me and he asked me to think
about the sense of having sex with with
Ben and then he electric stopped me
so we want to let people to know that
electric shock still exists and it hurt
our LGBT community
it took me a while to decide to seal the
clinical battle I know there are many
gay people like me have that situation
to be cure and there are many clinic in
China
we have to stop that this case could
tell the whole country in China and all
over the world
Hamas says so is not disease and he
needed a future today I'm going to see
my lawyer
who helped me to fill this case to clean
it up I do an all-nighter what Angela
thinking that much which I have made
dana jamison jess was a coach and I used
my vagina
Oh dr. Wilson is so hot mmm
Savannah so Gina will refer to the
animal I don't work for my opinion sir
please - enhance idea what you're
telling us - I said I'll see you ever
Julian s100 sound how you do but not you
have a loser
so yeah there's a 29% Oh July 29 for
civilian to short sale sale is really a
milestone and the ends will be recorded
in history yeah because this is the
first term LGBT people initiated a scan
on litigation so it's very inspirational
for LGBTQ community
I don't sing I'm ready because the pop
and the situation is very that someone
have to stand out to stop this because
if we don't stand out of the situation
we'll both end was what can tell we
Balkan down in adoulin patella
it's a master wah
I see
passing wave solutions Alma
Oh ciao Casanova
dude aha
oh wow now myself see de casa
the best result is the cause pronounced
commercial therapy is illegal
very important the results it changed
the people smile and we can use to lose
how to tell everybody there especially
tell the parents in China gay cannot be
changed